all right joining us now with is someone
who all too familiar with Joe Biden's
incompetence Ohio Senator J.D Vance is
with the center great to see you again
how are you
I'm good Sean thanks for having me what
happened to Joe's promise that he was
going to go to East Palestine whatever
happened did anybody ever help the
people out in that community
well it's shameful and disgraceful Sean
what happened is that over a hundred
days ago Joe Biden promised that he
would visit East Palestine and he has
broken that promise refused to visit and
more importantly Sean he has refused to
actually employ the services of his
government to help the people of East
Palestine I was there just a couple of
weeks ago and let me tell you people
feel abandoned and forgotten because
their own government their own president
who promised to show up didn't show up
and they really feel it when you compare
what's happening in East Palestine and
Maui you see a guy who promised he ran
for president saying that he would bring
decency and empathy back to the Oval
Office well Donald Trump showed up in
East Palestine and Joe Biden never did
and he hasn't shown up anywhere else
either I wish this guy would just stay
in his bunker and leave people alone but
if he's going to pretend to be the head
of our government he ought to get out
there and do his job
well yeah I would like to think so how
is the community doing because that was
that was really disastrous at the time
and how does a president make a promise
you know what are the things I always
believed as a parent if you make a
promise to your kids all right you get
straight A's I'm going to take you to
Disney or whenever the promise happens
to be you got to keep your promise if
they do their part you got to do your
part it's a president's job to show up
in Maui not two weeks later it's a
president's job if he tells the people
of Ohio he's going to go and he's going
to help them to show up uh why is this
so hard for this president
vacation
it's so hard Sean because I think that
he just doesn't care this is a guy who
ran for president to be called Mr
President not to actually do something
for the people of the country and you
see it every single day you ask how the
people of East Palestine are doing uh
Sean in a lot of ways they're still
struggling they're trying to rebuild I
think they're trying to come back and I
really believe it's one of the strongest
most hard-working most courageous groups
of of people that I've ever met so
they're going to come back stronger than
ever Sean but their government isn't
helping them and there are a lot of
problems that are still there number one
indoor air quality testing for people
who are living in areas where they're
still smelling toxic fumes the
government isn't doing it number two
cleaning up the creek cleaning up the
Watershed so that you don't have
poisonous waterways the government has
failed there as well so they're coming
back Sean but at the same time they're
coming back in an environment where the
government has failed them every single
day it's not good at all and I think
they'd be doing so much better if Joe
Biden got off his rear end it actually
used his government to serve the people
of this country for once yeah he seems
to fight harder for money for the people
of Ukraine than he does for people in
our own country I guess that's what
America last policies look like uh
Senator J.D Vance great to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else